comment vous enviez en garde à vue jean
michel vous allez passer aux mains mais
ça guillard mme jenny ton casier ancien
reporter de guerre en bosnie whetton
caractère qu'a dû passer plus de temps à
chercher des bombes dans des barques sur
le terrain jean michel maire ce nerf
d'une charrette que prendre cet air
décontracté avec moi parce que ça va pas
le faire en lavage pour les enquêtes de
tpm pète avait fait une épilation de
l'anus
y a pas à dire la télé ça change un
homme sa fac 1042 conquête
bah dis donc moi je suis à 12 enfin ça
c'est un autre problème c'est un
abattement 1042 femme d'environ un mètre
soixante allongée ça veut dire que tu as
quel 1500 km de femmes
mon dieu je comprends mieux qu'on engage
deux routiers maintenant on n'est pas ce
sourire
et qu'est ce que c'est que cette
obsession duisburg docteur zboub la
chaîne youtube et j'en passe fatah avant
dé plus de fois la question du pénis
qu'un durant l'inde en fin de carrière
qu'est ce qui s'est passé honte à
implanter des cheveux trop loin dans ton
servante était un mec brillant radio
presse bouquin bas quel moment ta
carrière est parti en beau en vrai
[Musique]
pas mal pas démérité